I am definitely, um,
keeping everybody at a distance
and making sure that even though we live with my boyfriend,
that there's no confusion that he's not their stepdad.
This is more like a little village setup,
because I am trying to protect my kids.
You know, when I had children,
it was in a marriage, and I was expecting that to last forever,
and that didn't. And so now I'm like,
I put my everything into that.
Like, it should have lasted forever
and it didn't. So since I have no control over what somebody else does,
I can't control how our relationship is gonna.
And, you know,
I wanted the first one to last forever,
and it didn't. So, um,
I. I don't want my kids to have a super,
super deep affection for my boyfriend.
I kinda want it to be like,
that's mommy's boyfriend, you know?
Like, I'm.
And I am 1,000% positive that this is like
my trauma and my issues that are causing this.
But it's how I feel most comfortable right now.
I don't want a boyfriend that wants to be their fucking stepdad.
I don't want someone that I have to figure out how to parent alongside
and still have to co parent with their actual father.
For me, as a mom,
it makes me feel uncomfortable.
It would make me feel uncomfortable if somebody was like,
trying to step in and be stepmom without meeting me
or like, without,
like, if It's not gonna truly be a blended family.
I feel like, okay,
then that just feels disrespectful to the other parent,
and I just don't wanna do that.
So, yeah,
I'm super duper just a single mom.
Like, he.
I've had a roommate for since I left my ex husband.
So it is truly like he's my roommate.
We just also happen to have a romantic relationship.
But, yeah,
that's kinda how I want it.
I just. Me and my kids have been through too much.
I don't want to sell them some fairy tale that Mommy met the one
and we're gonna be together forever.
You know, Mommy's living with her boyfriend right now.
We'll see how things go. Like,
that's just where my heart feels comfortable for right now.
Who knows if things can change, but.